[Music]
When you say you're feeling lonely.
All right, here we go guys. Another day.
Welcome everybody. Welcome. Welcome. If
you're watching video on demand, skip
through about 4 minutes. We will be
started very shortly
with farmer's life.
[Music]
Everything looks like it's working. Oh,
that's a good start. That's a good
start.
Excellent. Scrapn, how you doing, buddy?
Always good to see you, my friend. Love
having you here.
Hope you're having a great
day. All right, everything is working
today. Everything's going
[Music]
well, right? That's good to see. Well, I
better get this game started cuz I'm
pretty sure my character's going to fall
asleep.
[Music]
logged in the other day to send a
screenshot to somebody and I've got that
black screen again. Oh, cool. Blime me.
At least we know what it is now. It's
just my character falling asleep
standing up. I can understand that.
[Music]
Yep. He's asleep. I I knew it.
I'll wait for him to wake up this time
instead of starting with a black screen
like we did last time.
Come on, wake up. There we go. Right,
let's hold
that. Now, we need chats.
We want that one. We want that
one. Let's try text to speech. See if we
get that one working
today. I need to add those. I'm going to
try and get to that this week. I do not
have any
of the blurps working in here. Was it a
blurp? I think it was.
Um, I need to go back to installing that
software. We've been testing for a
couple of weeks now. We know everything
else is working. I think what I'll do is
I'll go back to running my source clone
this week.
source plane will bring all that
[Music]
back. Yeah, unfortunately we had issues.
So, I switched extra stuff off and never
added that one
back. All right, let's jump into this,
shall
we? Hello and welcome to today's live
stream. I'm Glenn Bixley and we are back
with more Farmers Life. Welcome
everybody. So, first thing we'll do as I
always do, we take a bit of a look
around just to see where we are. Okay,
so the still is still running. Get it?
Still still. Oh, okay. I'll come down.
Uh, next bottle. 2 hours 45. Got 27
hours on the clock. There's Dez. How you
been, my friend? Good to have you here,
Dez. Thank you, buddy. I don't know if I
say it enough, but you're a great
moderator. and I do appreciate you. Uh,
blueberry mash will be ready in 11
minutes.
Okay, 11 minutes. We got 28:00. So,
we're all right there. We're all right
there. Okay. Now, for anyone that might
be new, welcome. This is This is our
farm in the dark. Let's switch our
lights on. There we
go. So, in the last couple of weeks,
what we've done is we have built a
pigsty recently.
We've built all new sheds. You'll get to
see them better in the daylight. Uh we
do have all these new sheds built, which
we can have a look at shortly. We have a
new chicken coupe. We have a new
entrance way and a new mushroom
farm. And we have 30 hours on those
potatoes. Right.
So, let's go to bed and wake up in the
morning and let's get this day started.
What was our temperature, by the way?
We're coming into winter, I think.
18°. Yes, it's getting a little cold.
Okay, okay.
All right. So, yes, let's go to bed. We
shall wake
up. 10 hours sleep sounds pretty good.
I think cuz we're coming into
winter. No, let's go with a 10hour
sleep. We'll do some longer sleeps in
winter, I think. Let's actually see how
that sets us anyway for
stamina. Oh, I've never noticed that.
So, even the night takes a little
longer. Okay. While you're sleeping.
Okay, we do have full stamina.
Excellent. Yeah, everything's a little
slower now. We changed our clock speed
or at least our game speed last week and
I am now
playing with reduced speed. We're at
0.1
speed which I am finding a lot more
relaxing and
enjoyable. Really love the slower speed.
Uh let's grab Oops, wrong
button. I keep forgetting. You can't do
that. Uh, let's drag you over and we'll
grab eight is more than enough. We only
need like two.
Probably three. Oh, there you go. I
wasn't far
off. All right. Next bottle is what? 1
hour 42. Okay. And we still have mash.
So, let's throw that back in there. We
have six bottles of moonshine to sell.
Beautiful. Why am I holding on to some
mash? cuz I just took that off the stove
clean. All right, I think what we should
do today is buy some more distilleries.
Now, I've had a few people criticize
that I only have one
still. And considering I brew in real
life, I do agree. One still, it's just
still not
enough. Uh,
let's Oops, not the lights. No, not the
lights. The door thingy. Right. Thank
you. Let's have a quick drink of some
water. We'll go check on our animals.
Make sure they're all
good. We'll grab some food as we go and
do our rounds. Actually, let's just cuz
this is so much more organized now.
Let's do our rounds properly. We
need a
pitchfork. We need a
brush. Oh, we need our coffee. Oh, we've
actually got some in there. Actually,
we'll leave some in the tool shed. I
think that's probably a good idea. All
right. All
right. This is so much more organized.
Look at that. We can go straight from
there to
there. 116 food. Oh, that might be a
little too much. Oh, no. We can carry
more now. I forgot I also turned up the
carry capacity so I wouldn't have to
spend so much time running back and
forth all the time cuz that can be a
little boring to watch as a live stream.
We've got the pretty good idea on how
the base game runs now with
time as well
as Oops. The cat is still missing. Yes.
Um with time and everything else. We
pretty much got that sus now. Can you
move? Cuz I want to get that food
without getting you. All right. Um we'll
clean this place up before I brush them.
I think this is much nicer with fewer
picks.
I should clean up the dung. I did.
So now we've got a few less pigs or
fewer fewer. Yeah, we got less pigs and
there's a lot more space in here. Hey
Fluffy, this is certainly a lot easier
to get around. The only thing is we're
going to want some of this done for our
fields in spring. Hopefully there'll be
enough. All
right, let's clean these guys up.
Actually, if I put that on two and I put
the pitchfork
on one, that'll make it easier. Right
now, we can just hot pee these. So,
well, yes, we'll just feed the animals.
We'll clean up the place a little bit.
There's a bit done I
missed. And then we'll figure out what
we got to do. So, we are coming up
towards winter now. I have one small
potato crop.
Other than
that, we're pretty much just getting
ready for what's going to be my longest
winter. And I say that because of the
slower time, but it may mean all these
jobs that I keep saying I will do in
winter are finally going to be able to
get done. So, this enclosure here, the
pigs die, was one I've been trying to do
for about 3 years in
game in game years, I mean, and never
actually managed to get it done until
last winter. So much nicer. I think
we'll keep all the trees and everything
in here. I kind of like those for the
pig sty. That's right. This is a small
gate, isn't it? I keep forgetting about
that one.
Uh, our berries all along the back of
the house. We got some wood there. All
right, so we got to clean up a little
bit this winter. Do we brush sheep? We
do.
I stepped on dung. Damn it. Oh, well, we
better clean that up
first. All right, we'll give the give
the ladies a haircut. Uh, not a haircut.
Sorry. Give him a brush. We'll clean up
all this
dung. Hey, Mumu.
How are
you? Oh, this is so much better with
less
animals. You don't step in it everywhere
you go.
My shoes wreak. I didn't step in it, did
I? Oh, man. Now my shoes are going to
stick all
day. It's so much easier to clean up
when you got less animals. I think what
I need to do as part of our new
organization this
winter will
be to make separate areas for each
animal. So, this will be for the cows.
At the moment, the sheep are in here.
Oh, I need another bin back here, don't
I? I do. No, we got this one. We got the
original one. I forgot about it. Right.
That's the very first one. Right. Why
are you sleeping in the dung
pile? Recovering after giving birth 1
month. Okay, you will live for 15. So,
we might sell you this year. Well, maybe
it wasn't you. Maybe it was a
rat. Uh, fatness pregnant seven month
not have get back here and I'm brushing
you. Lamb chops. I remember watching
lamb chops when I was a kid. Was that
not the lamb chops you
me? We could make lamb chops. We
certainly
could. Hey, get back here. Right, you're
done. All right. I love lamb. Lamb is my
favorite meat. I have to say I eat a lot
of chicken, but that's cuz it's cheap.
When I was a kid, lamb used to be cheap.
Some of you have probably heard that New
Zealand's in the country with more sheep
than people. That's true, but we need
more sheep in this country. We used to
have more and now there's not enough.
Lamb is so expensive here. Used to be a
really cheap meal. All right, let's uh
actually we're going to need we're going
to need probably a bin in here. Let's do
that
now to keep a milking bucket. That's not
what you meant to
press. Cuz I would
like a milking bucket
here. A
chest. Big chests, aren't
they? So, we might build this this
winter just
to make sure that we
have stuff for the cows.
Oh, tree needs material. I keep
forgetting in this game you have to have
materials to lay down a blueprint. Um,
that's all right. We'll get to it. Okay,
you can cancel the blueprint now. Thank
you. We'll get to that. So, that'll be
something we'll do during this winter as
well. Right. Let's throw some food in
[Music]
here.
Excellent. Shut that. Actually, that's
right. I left the other side open in
case chickens decide to come in here.
Now, we've got no animals in here at the
moment. All right. Do we brush the dog
in this game? I've never thought about
it. Let's try brushing the
dog. Oh, you're 100% clean. Still have
not seen the cat. No, no idea where the
cat's gone, but there is food in the
cat's bowl, so that's not an excuse.
Maybe we could try finding the cat
today, cuz we did find some animals last
week.
amazed at the amount of animals we found
with slower time period. Is there a
bucket in here? We could use this one
instead of the shed bucket. Oh, I want
that. And we'll give that to the
pigs. We'll give that to the pigs. So,
they have a second food
bowl. All right. Uh, wrong button.
inventory. If I bring the tractor
through that
way, let's actually just pop it over
here. Make it nice and easy when they're
side by
side. There we go. Plenty of food for
the pigs. No excuse for them to not
fatten up this season. Cuz last year
they got a bit skinny. When we sold
them, they were all very skinny. I'm
going to keep the brush. I was about to
get rid of it, but let's see. Oh, yeah.
Okay. Stupid idea. I was about to say,
let's see if we can brush a chicken or a
duck. How you going to catch it,
Glenn? Right. Now that we've got a lot
of food trays in here, we should end up
with more chickens and ducks this year
as well.
Now, in this game, you do not need to
worry about the eggs you take
from the nests. They don't prevent the
chickens from breeding. You can take
them
all. When I first started, I was leaving
eggs behind cuz I wanted the chickens to
breed. And then it didn't seem to make
any difference. So, I
Googled. And according to the developers
on
Steam, it says you don't need to worry
about
it. Some of those uh Steam forums are
pretty good and you need
help. All
right, go check our mushrooms. I think
our mushrooms are going to need another
day or so. But we do
have chicken. I'm going to brush. I'd
watch out if I was you. I think I
actually managed to brush that
chicken. I heard the noise. All right.
Why are you not There we go. Okay. So,
yeah, we got a couple of
days. We are going to run out of manure.
We're going to need more animals just
for the manure. Interesting. Unless we
start buying
poo. What's the best place to click?
I've been clicking hack, but I don't
think Oh, maybe it is. I say I don't
think it is, but I don't
know cuz see when you click these they
highlight. Oh no, it did work. I must
have just missed before. Oh well, we're
all good. Yeah, they have a day to go.
We have another day on the potatoes. 19
hours. All right, let's put our tools
away. So, our sheds that we have, this
is our new repair shed. We can actually
repair our items. I wonder if a brush
ever needs repairs.
Do brushes ever need repairs? I had
never thought about it
before. I've never actually repaired. I
don't know how to repair this. Ah, that
won't make sense. What about this?
I don't know how to repair it. Is that
cuz it's not broken? All right. We have
our new sewing shed. Last week, we made
a whole lot of new clothes. So, we made
a night gown for when we get married.
And we also
made was
it not bear fur? No. We also made
which set was it?
Welcome Michelle. How are
you? Red set. Oh, we might need to get a
red set. We need three wool and
raspberry. Oh, we can actually make
that. I might make some more cloves
today. I want to see a few more of the
clothing items. Um, nothing you can
actually do in here. This is the sharing
shed, but you don't actually need it. So
long as you've got a sharing shed and
you've got clippers, you can share your
sheep. I don't know who you're going to
share them with, but it's always nice to
share, isn't it? All
right, let's pop those away. Pop the
rest of this food
away. Oh, okay.
Is that all the food we have? I might
have to think about
that. We're going through a lot of food
right now. Okay. So, what do we have in
the
dugout? Okay. Is that cooked fish? Fried
fish. Well, fried fish does not need to
be in the dugout. It won't go
rotten. I don't know if these go rotten.
That's an interesting one. We might have
to try that this year. I think I did
last season, actually. I think I did
last season.
Um, I think they did go
wrong. Oh, sorry. I'm thinking what is
that game noise? It's not actually a
game noise. It's sitting outside. All
right. Put our fish away. We don't
really need that. We'll put our eggs
away for now. We're not going to the
shop right now. Okay. Yes. Welcome
everybody. I hope everybody is having a
brilliant day. And if you're new to the
channel, thank you for uh joining us. I
hope you subscribe because we've got a
very friendly
community and I am so happy to have
every one of you here. Uh let's do some
more cooked ham. Requires a stove
burning. That generally tends to be a
thing.
So yes, thank you everybody whether you
be a subscriber, channel
member. I definitely appreciate every
last one of you. I don't say it
enough. All right, we'll throw the ham
on. An hour and a half. We got plenty of
time. I've got to better make sure it
doesn't burn. But because we're not
actually moving time so fast now, I
should be all right with that. Actually,
we could go sell all of
this and our
eggs. What are we at? 22. Wait. Let's
grab our eggs and anything else we have
to
sell. I'm going to sell these
because we can't use three. We need
four. And you can't plant
them. Excuse me. can't plant
them. So, I think if we take that I
haven't milked the cows yet. I got to
milk the cows before I
go. What is that? That's our sourdough.
True. That's something I need to try in
real life. Making sourdough. I've never
made sourdough. Thanks for the dono.
Oh, $2. Thank you, script mech.
Appreciate it, mate. Thank
you. Can we sell Mark? We would never do
that. You know better than that. Why
would you do
that? Where would we be without people
like you and
Mark? I mean, I appreciate all of you
guys. We'd never sell you. Okay, we do
actually have a lot of broth I could
sell. Now, somebody was asking the other
day on the Discord how to make broth.
And in all honesty, I don't remember how
I made that. But the answer from the
developers looked a lot more complicated
than I thought.
Apparently getting the recipe is a bit
of trial and error. Bit of
experimentation. What are you doing the
wiggle
for? I haven't got him on leash by
chance, have I? So apparently there's a
bit of
experimentation. We're getting the right
brute. What is your problem? Come
here. I don't know what his problem
is. I can't even get him out of the
door. All right, that's a load of
bull. Never mind. Let's milk the cows.
What? What' that say? Everything works
just fine, but there's no milk yet.
What's your problem? Fatness
96%. Pregnant 3
months.
Oh, we might have to wait for her to
give
birth. Let's Let's put you out in the
field for the
day. Oh, we got two from that one. We're
going to let you out for the day as
well. Come on, ladies. Come and enjoy
the day. You didn't get a brush though.
That's probably not
good. We'll get to you guys later or
ladies
actually cuz you're both at 95%. Come
over here where the food is. That hell
got out. I just
noticed. What happened to your friend?
Did I not have her on the
lead? I do. Okay.
She's having issues. Okay, we're having
a couple of issues today. That's all
right. At least now we're not in such a
rush. Little issues like that used to
stress me out a bit
because with the time flow Oh, you're
right there. What are you trying to
do with the time flow? It made it really
frustrating cuz you'd spend 5 10 minutes
trying to sort them out.
Not such a problem now that time is
slow. We'll ignore them. We'll move
on. All right. So, that's all of our
little jobs done. Where should I put
this bucket? Cuz I really need the
bucket for milking the
cows. What did I just
see? Oh, the
dog. All
right. So, let's I think we should go
and buy ourselves a new still. Get
another one
going. And then what we could probably
do is use the
stills to make more
income. Okay, so we have Okay, let's put
the milk away. I'm not selling my milk.
We use that for making butter. We're
probably better off to sell the butter,
but at the moment, all my butter's been
getting used for cooking cuz we're doing
a lot of cooking in game at the
moment. Okay. All right. All right.
We're good. Everything's good. See you
guys. An hour and 16
minutes. I Oh, the last king of retail.
I thought you meaning there's another
one. What is it?
Retail. The first one was really good.
Oh, it's King of Retail.
Yeah. Oh, sorry. Okay. I misread. Yes.
King of Retail 2. It's actually out. Is
it? That looks Well, I don't know about
King of Retail, too, but I saw that the
other day. Where's my
bike? And King of Retail looked like a
really cool
game. I don't know where my bike is. Oh,
well, how's anybody going to say on your
bike if we don't know where it is? Did I
leave it in town or is it over
here? Are you saying no to the potatoes,
dog? You don't have to eat them.
Maybe my bike's over here. Oh, there's a
goose in the shed. Here's my bike. All
right. Hey, you guys can s your bike.
Oh, too late. I'm already on
it. Let's have a look in this shed and
see what's
here. Let's just see what's
here. I'm curious to know. No, that's
the wrong one for this game. It's E.
Oops. Oh, so we do have more food. I was
thinking I'm sure we have more food.
Yeah, we do. We do. I'll sort that out
when we get back or at least in winter.
something. All right.
So, things found by Telka. Oh, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes. That was last week.
All
right. All the pigs are home
now.
Okay. Keep getting off on the wrong side
of the bike. Our trailer's here, too.
Maybe we can take that home.
[Music]
All right, you'll buy the
eggs.
Oops. Where's
Henry? Has he just not spawned
in? Where is
Henry? Usually Henry the drunk is
standing in the middle of town and
trying to pick a fight for no reason.
Uh, actually, we don't need to go to
everybody, Glenn. We just need to go to
the ones that you have goods
for. No Costa. Nope. We haven't got to
her yet.
We'll get to her in a
sec. Right. We'll sell that to you cuz
we're going to have to go sell the rest
of our eggs to the no cost
lady.
Um, you'll buy that.
You'll buy
these. Oh, we should have used these
pelts. Oh, there wasn't
enough. I want to make some money today.
Well, what about making pelts in winter?
We can go hunting in winter. Oh, why am
I trying to sell that to
you? Can we pet the doggy? I want to pet
the dog. Can I pet that dog? Oh, sorry.
Oh, here is here.
Henry's here.
Um, I don't know where Henry got to, but
he's here now. Are you not going to buy
my beets? You are going to buy my beets.
I just didn't try. You have already sold
out on eggs. Yeah, they only sell so
much of a certain produce. So, if you've
got too much, they will not buy it. You
need to take it to the state farm.
So, what we might do is grab our trailer
today cuz
apparently I left it here for whatever
reason last
week. Well, that sent it flying.
Okay, let's try this again. Not sure why
that didn't connect. Can you stay
standing? Oh, said stay
standing.
No. What am I doing wrong? Attach. Thank
you. Right. So, we get this trailer
home. Then I
think we should go buy a new
still. How much money did we have? Two
grand. That's enough. I'm pretty sure
that's enough. Matt, it's fast travel
home. 1 minute.
All
right, detach
that. Um, whoops. Stuck, stuck, stuck.
Right. So, now another thing discussed
on the Discord for any of you who are
from the Farmers Life Discord. I did say
I have most of the equipment cuz
somebody was wondering about equipment.
So, of course, this is your original
tractor. It's generally found over that
way somewhere. I think next to here. You
need to put it together using the
wrench. So if you when you start, you'll
have a wrench, pretty sure. Otherwise,
you can go and purchase one. When you
walk up to the tractor with the wrench,
it will then tell you what parts are
required to fix it. I have the trailer.
One of the most important things you'll
need. We have the lawn
mower. We have a tiller cuz somebody was
suggesting that the game needs a tiller.
Uh sorry, a a plow. So this is our three
row plow. There is also a single row
plow I believe as well. But this is the
three row. Then you've got the digger.
So that is what we use to dig out our
potatoes and other
vegetables. Then we have our manure
spreader. What a load of that is.
Uh sorry I had to.
Um and then of course our cedar.
Probably the most important of all of
our vehicles is the cedar. And I forgot
we had tobacco in the ground. 32 hours.
Excellent. All right. So, that is most
of the equipment. There may be a few
other items that I haven't as yet got
to, but that is the bulk of
it. Okay. So, we're going to head down
now to the state farm and go sell the
rest of our
eggs. I don't know why I always turn
around. Oh, that was the other two
pieces of equipment we purchased. Well,
we had one for a while. We have the
threshers. So, these are the big
thresher, which you put your grain crops
into. It will give you wheat or other
grains, but it also gives you straw for
feeding your
animals. And then down here, don't run
that way, goose. I'm scaring you. Like
we have the small threshes which we put
some of
our hay into and and then of course we
get our foder as well as we get straw
from that. Right. Let's fast
travel. Is it an? I don't think it is an
but oh wait I shouldn't have done that.
Okay let's let's go and see. I'm pretty
sure it's not Anne. I think I've come to
the wrong person, but I was meant to go
all the way into town first
anyway. How you doing,
Anne? So, yeah. No, Anne does not sell
the stills. I didn't think
so. Okay. I think that's Thaddius's
wife. Pretty sure that's Thaddius's
wife. But we need to go sell the rest of
these
eggs. There we go. No
Costa. All right. Check the board. Check
our prices. So, we are here to sell
eggs. So, you can see all your prices
for everything on here basically. No
eggs though cuz eggs is not a crop.
Glenn, you can't grow eggs. What are you
crazy? Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, it is only
it's only crops that you grow. Okay. All
right.
Mimi sprry. Mimi sprry. Exactly. Yeah.
Buy some eggs off me, love. 500 bucks.
Nice. That gives us 2 six.
Excellent. Right. Two six should be more
than enough to buy us still. Pretty sure
that's Thaddius's
wife. Let's go visit the wife. Fadius
isn't important to us right now. How you
doing? Helen, that's your name. Okay, so
a
distillery. They are
1,120 each, so we can afford
two. Freaking awesome. All right. All
right. All
right. Tobacco, but not tobacco
seed.
68. We might be able to make some money.
buying
tobacco, rolling cigarettes, which I
really hate doing cuz it's such a thing
that my brain doesn't work with. That's
something we might try this winter.
Actually, we've only got 400 bucks
left. Okay, let's try that. I'm going to
see if we can take $400 worth of tobacco
and make money out of it.
And if you want to buy any com of your
tractor parts, anything you need to
assemble your tractors, this uh nice
fine young man here will sell you your
bicycle, your
trailers, your motor for your equipment,
all your tools, including the wrench
that you need to fix the
tractor, and then of course your tractor
parts and a saw bench. So any of your
tractor parts that you need to assemble
your tractor, they're all right here.
Um, yeah, cuz I know somebody on the
Discord was having a bit of trouble
trying to figure out how to get their
tractor
running. So, there's where you get all
your parts. That's what you need. Let's
head back home with our two new
stills. Now, we might end up
finding Oh, you're going to stand now.
Like we might end up finding
that we don't have enough room in this
kitchen. Actually, I have an
idea. Disassemble the table. We don't
need that anymore. We're going to get
new furniture this season, too.
I want to get all new furniture this
season.
Uh we're just going to pop that there.
Look at this rag. A rug. I was going to
call it a rag. It looks like a bit of a
rag, doesn't it? God blow me. Uh, I
actually think what we could do is
we rotate this
cabinet. Now, do I have to put it down
or can I put it? No, that's what I
thought.
Put it down first.
We'll make this our brewing kitchen. I
mean, um, is it the stall in the way? Is
the rug in the way? Cancel.
Only.
Whoops, wrong button. Uh, can't remember
how to rotate in this game. This is our
stool for rolling our tobacco. Pop that
down
there. Can I move a still while it's
still running? Oh, sorry.
Um. Oh, I can. Don't know if that was a
good idea or a bad idea, but we did
it. And then what we can do,
pop you out of the way for now.
Um, actually I can pop you back here
because that's now moved. But I want to
be able to see out my window. So, let's
grab this. Grab you out of the way.
Oh, there's another thermometer here.
Well, I've never even noticed this.
Let's just pop it up there for now. I'm
going to rearrange the room to make us a
little bit more space.
There's still room.
Right.
Silent protagonist thing. I got it
laughed and I turned it off not knowing
what it did. And now that he's back to
moaning again, I kind of missed
it. I kind of like listening to him
moan. I don't know why.
It's going a bit further, I
think. Hard up against the wall. That's
what we
want. All right. I used Oh, I was going
to say thought it was working for a sec.
What happened to the
wood? Did we lose the wood when I picked
it up? We lost everything when I picked
it
up. All right. I should have left it
alone. Should have waited, but never
mind. What's done is done. Oh, that's
what I
believe. What about that cupboard when I
picked up that cupboard? Oh, that still
has a stuff in it. That still has stuff
in it. And that still has stuff in it.
Okay, so we didn't lose all of that at
least. That's good. What I might do,
though, is I'm going to pack up these
cupboards, cuz we don't use them. We
don't need
them. And I want to make a bit more
space in this kitchen for the brute.
Uh, it's all one covered. I'm pretty
sure this is I've never pulled this one
apart. Let's disassemble. It's all one
covered. I thought it was
right. Just going to get this stuff out
of here for
now. And this will just give us a bit
more space in the
kitchen. That's fine.
Why are you off to one side? That is
really
awkward.
Okay. And now we've got enough space for
one more still. We still have space for
a still. Something like that. That plate
up.
All right. I think I like that. Much
better. Much better. We can put another
cabinet down here, actually. All
right. So, we have 24 minutes left on
the ham. Okay. Excellent. Yeah. When I
took picked this up, we lost everything.
We lost the wood. We lost the water.
That's a real shame. And we also lost
the mash and any else that was in it. I
don't think there was any brew cuz we
actually picked that up.
Okay, we need another bucket as
well. There's a few things I want to get
on top of this winter. Now that we got
more time, we're going to be able to do
that. Excuse
me. I'm just a little
um disappointed we lost all of that
wood. There was quite a bit of wood in
that
distillery, but never mind.
Oh, saved. Okay. No, the
stills. So, what we're going to
do, let's get all these stills ready to
go. We can get all three of them started
now. And we'll use the money from
these to get another one.
Actually, you know what I should have
done? I should have taken the booze that
we had in that
cupboard and sold that to get another
one. We still
could. I think the actually the lady
that sells us the stills will buy our
booze. All right. Yeah, it's a pity we
lost at
wood. That would not be good. Uh, so
where do we have wood? I'm just going to
check. I'm pretty confident there's
nothing in
here. I think there might be some in
here for
repairs. 14. It's not a
lot. It's not a lot. We're going to take
it. We're going to have to find some
more. We might have to go out this
winter and just find wood.
Oh, we are going to have to get more
wood.
Okay. Is that going to be enough wood to
at least get the three stills
running? We
go.
Five. Five.
Let's just try that for now while I've
still got some. So, blueberry mash, not
raspberry mash. Ah,
stink. I want to do an apple mash.
Actually, we got three stills. We
could do apple mash in
one
start. Oh, this one's having trouble
starting. Here we go.
Okay, 3
hours. Give it another bit of wood.
Okay, we have enough wood to do that.
Excellent. We'll do potato mash in
here. Yeah, I had a lot of wood in
there. I lost. Never mind. That's
life. Okay. We're going to need to get
some more
wood. the mash
back. And we've got empty jars. They can
go.
Oh, might put some jars in here for
now. I think what we should do sell this
booze. Now I have flowers. What am I?
Oh, flowers could go over here in the
cupboard with the flowers on it. There's
yeast in here. I must have run out of
space and put yeast in there. I didn't
know it was in there.
We need to put that in the other
cupboard. Just going to stick all of
this in here for
now. More
yeast. We could do more bread then. All
right. Uh let's pop this down
somewhere. Right here will
do. and we'll pop you
down. Right, that might light up our
kitchen a little bit. Now, I'm going to
do the cigarettes
later cuz I don't want to confuse the
money from the brew. Let's go sell this
brew. Actually, I'm just going to leave
this bucket in
here. Tobacco. We have more
tobacco than I thought. 27 tobacco.
Okay, we'll get to that shortly. Should
I? No, let's just do it all in one
go. Actually, I'm not going to do what I
thought. I'm going to leave that till
later. What we're going to
do, let's roll some cigarettes. Now, I
have a bit of issues with this. So, you
put down your paper and your tobacco.
Then you
get the dot has to stay inside the bike
bar, but my brain always looks at it
differently. And I used to try and keep
the white
bar to keep up with the red dot, which
is completely wrong. You got to keep the
red dot inside the white
bar. Jeez, I've got more right today so
far. Doing
well. Nope. We're definitely not lost.
So, we'll go sell all this booze. We'll
sell these
cigarettes. We'll go and get ourselves
another
still. And then we're going to have to
find some more wood.
Now, cigarettes can be used to
bribe or make friends. Are you bribing
people or are you making friends?
You need them anyway to bring up the
level of friendship between you and some
of the
traders. Some people will like
cigarettes. Oh, that's what we needed
cigarettes for today. We needed to bribe
somebody. Sorry, not bribe. It's
probably the wrong word. Excuse me for a
sec. I'm going to take my jacket off.
Caught my throat. It's croaky
today. Get my jacket off. Starting to
warm up now. Sun's out.
It's winter, so I've got my window uh my
curtains open, letting the sunlight in.
During summer, I tend to keep my
curtains closed.
Keep the house cooler.
But yeah, I forgot we need these
cigarettes in order to make friends
with
somebody. I don't recall who it was,
though.
really can't recall
who we needed the cigarettes for. We
might have to go around and visit
everybody.
Oops. Screwed that one up. Let's do it
again. But I do remember last week we
went to
try and trade with
somebody. It makes no sense to start
without any tobacco. Yeah, you're right.
It does. We went to trade with somebody
last
week, but we did not have a high enough
friendship
level. So, we need to sort that out
today. Okay. So, that'll be ready in 7
minutes. So, we'll have to sort that out
before we go
anywhere. Oh, it would have been this
one. Next spot already.
said one of the bottles was ready. I
swear it said a bottle was
ready. I don't know. But we're going to
run out of wood real soon. All right. I
think what I might do very quickly is
we'll just go and look for some
wood. We are going to need
it. already picked it all up out
here. Now I can probably cut these
logs into firewood. It's not really a
good use for Oh, that's um not really
the best
use. This is what we really need.
Sticks.
Um take it all. It's not much. It's not
much. Yeah. We'll very quickly go over
here into the trees, get some wood so we
can get those stills running. I have to
wait seven minutes anyway for the ham to
be
cooked. Quite
full. And we need to do these while
we're out.
only sticks out in the trees is
not the best way to get away. Oh,
there's berry picking to do. All right.
Well, that's what we're going to do
then. We're going to get berries. We're
going to get mushrooms. And we're going
to get
sticks. We'll kill eight birds with one
rock or whatever that expression is.
Yeah, I hope you guys are enjoying this
game. I am. I'm thoroughly enjoying it.
It's a great little
game and the developers are listening to
feedback. So, if you do have the
game and you'd like to make suggestions,
okay, there's no sticks in here. You got
suggestions or
ideas, the developers are listening.
They have a big list apparently of
things they want to do.
Give me a second. I need to clear my
throat.
All right. I don't know why I'm so
croaky
today. Don't know why I'm so croaky.
Don't really like to cough or clear my
throat when the mic's on. I try to mute
it. All
right. Yeah, we'll get some sticks.
We'll get some berries. We'll get some
uh
mushrooms. And then I think we need at
least one more still to finish that
kitchen. We might get more more of them
later. But for now, the big problem is
going to be keeping enough wood to keep
them all burning. So, there's no point
me going out and buying 12 stills and
then only be able to afford to run a
couple cuz of wood. That makes no sense
at all. That would make no
sense. It's still a bad idea. Oh, okay.
I'll stop with the
puns. They're not punny.
There's
two. We definitely need to come back and
do a bit more of this today, actually.
Oh, where's the hit box? Stop being
awkward. Thank
you, silly little stick.
We should have brought the rifle as well
so we could do some hunting. Come back
in a
minute. All right, we'll get those hams
off the
stove. We're going to need to cut all
this firewood this winter. We'll use
this for building next season.
Another question that somebody had asked
on this Discord was in regards to making
money out of selling wood from growing
trees. I wouldn't know because I've put
all my wood so far into building.
Right, there's another four hams on.
Hour and 25 hour and 30. Perfect. We're
not going to burn that lot, are we?
Um, I'll throw my berries in the
cupboard. So, we're going to make mash
out of those
probably. Uh, we want to put
the sticks into them
stills. I'm just going to put these
tools in here for now just to get rid of
them. We're going to leave the
cigarettes cuz we don't need to be
carrying
them. And we'll come back to that bottle
of booas
later. Oh, setting this one. I'll get
the order of those right
soon. All right. So, how are we doing?
You have
three, you have two, and you have one.
Okay. Let's give
you I didn't really do math very well at
school. 10 for you. That's
11. Give you half roughly.
I'll give you half
roughly. Okay, they all have around
about 10 each. Excellent. Now, how much
time do they have though? Burning for 4
and 1/2 hours. We're good. And 10
sticks. Seven uh 7 hours. 10 sticks.
Yep. 7 hours and 11. Yep. We're good.
We're
good. Okay. Actually, what I'd like to
do before we take off
again. Is it raspberry
mash? Don't need all of
that. And wool. Do I have any more
wool? I think we have some out in the
shed out side. I hope we
do. Otherwise, we might try and share
some sheep. I don't know how often you
can share sheep in this game. In real
life, you only share them once a
year. We do have wool. Okay, some
wool, some string. And why not? We might
actually try shearing some more sheep.
See if we can do it again. In theory, I
shouldn't be able to. No harm in trying,
though. Right. Now, I wanted to
try the red set. Raspberry mash. Is it?
That's what we have. Raspberries. Oh,
Glenn. Yes. It's not mash. It's
raspberries. We need to make the mash.
Oh, fine. Be like
that. Did we have raspberry mash?
No. No. Blueberry mash.
Okay. There's a difference. There is.
We'll get to that later. for now. Throw
all of this back in
here. Let's go try shearing some sheep.
Oops. I'm just going to drop it in
there. We got plenty of space in there
right now. I don't think we can, but it
be interesting to see. The sheep are not
in here. That's
pigs. They look similar, but they're not
the same.
Right. I don't think this should
work. Can we shear them every m every
day?
We can shear the sheep every day. We're
going to end up with a lot of wool.
You have to have a sharing shed. You
haven't got a sharing shed.
Don't worry, pal. I'm not going to try
shearing you.
Right. Let's try fixing you cuz the fact
that you're broken is kind of bothering
me. You're not going to move, are
you? Is it? I haven't done the math on
that. Let's fix this cow. Now, one thing
that the developers said to me, if you
have any issues with any of the animals
getting
stuck, put them on the lead and fast
travel them to the entrance uh to your
gate. And so far, that rule has
worked cuz yeah, I was having a few
issues with occasionally the animals do
get a bit stuck in their path, but that
was the advice from the developers.
stick him on a um
lead and then just fast travel to the
gate. Right. Uh actually, we'll keep the
wool on us cuz we put the other wool
inside. No, I won't empty out my
inventory. Got other jobs to do. Glenn,
let's head back. We'll do some more
berry picking. Actually, if we take a
bicycle and at least ride it up to the
tree
line. That'll just hopefully get us here
a little quicker. I don't know if it
actually does or
not. Um, where should we start? I think
up here in this corner. We can always
find the bike next to this
tree. Yeah,
exactly. All
right. So, we'll get some more berries,
sticks, mushrooms.
Let's look at the map for a sec. We're
heading up to Thaddius. That's where
we're actually going.
Oh, but I didn't bring I didn't bring
the booze with me.
Doesn't
matter. I have it. Thank you.
All
right. Yeah, it's actually really nice
to have the time to just come out and do
this cuz I have not had time to get out
and pick up sticks and Oh, I didn't
bring the rifle. That's your fault, Dez.
You didn't remind me. And speaking of
reminding, I need to bring my chat back
up. Put it down when I'm muted cuz I
always like to make sure that it
unmutes with the mic I've got doesn't
actually have a light on it. So, you
can't tell if I've muted or
unmuted. And I like to visually
check. All right.
Oh,
pardon. Well, this should keep our STS
running for a
day. We'll make a whole lot of
mash. And then I think next
season if we've got four stills or maybe
five. I'm actually thinking five is a
really good round number. Oh, we're
getting a bit of
freezing. We got five
stills. The amount of booze that we'll
be able to make in a day, we should be
better make some pretty good
money. And now that we've got the better
chicken coupe, our chickens will start
to well chickens and ducks now will
start to breed. And we should get a few
more of them. In the
past, they were kind of struggling to
get enough food between all of
them, and they weren't breeding very
well. I am kind of keen to see how much
wood we would get if we cut up a log.
But at the moment, I don't know if it's
going to be worth
doing. I probably want to start growing
some
trees. I wonder I've not growing any
trees in this game. Should we try
growing a
tree? Is it a tree, not an ice cream?
Told you I should have brought the
rifle. Need to remember that when you go
out from now on when we go out berry
picking. We've also got to get
sticks,
mushrooms, take the rifle, and then what
we need is little areas where we can
just dump everything on the edge of the
forest. Empty our inventory out. near a
road
somewhere. See, like this would be a
perfect spot. It's next to Thaddius's
farm. It's really easy to remember where
it is. And if we drop this stuff on the
edge of the road, it's really easy to
find. So, that's what we might have to
start doing in future.
I want to know if we can sell clothing
this winter as well. Who would we sell
clothing
to? I'm guessing it would be the shop in
town, the general store.
No mushrooms here. Oh, there's some.
Yeah, I'm definitely preferring this
more relaxed speed. I like
this. Oh, it's a fox. I was thinking,
was that one of my sheep? No, it's a
fox. A white fox. I bet you we could
make a really cool piece of clothing out
of a white fox. Isn't it terrible when
Glenn now looks at animals and thinks
clothing,
food? Yeah, there's animals that look at
us that think food,
too. Bet lions in Africa look at people
and think food.
There's more mushrooms that went
past. All right.
Who's that? Oh, it's a stick. So, we
probably didn't get you
there. Now, I've remapped my farmer's
vision to my middle mouse
button. I think it started out as Z, but
I was having issues with that cuz I had
to keep looking at my keyboard.
So, I've remapped it. I still have the
Z. I think it's
C. Yeah, it is. Yep. But I don't tend to
use
it. Middle mouse button is a lot more
convenient. Some of these sticks I'm
picking up
twice. Not going to complain.
We're getting on
42. When I first started, this is how I
made all my
money. I've had people on the Discord
asking what's the best way to make
money. I don't know. I haven't figured
that out
yet, but this is a really good
convenient way to get
started. Oh, it's a deer. I was
thinking, is that one of my sheep? Why
do I keep thinking everything's my
sheep? I don't know about Rich,
but hey, we do all right, I think,
considering this is how we started the
game and we were struggling to make any
money.
Now, when we have a harvest,
go out, spend good amounts of money.
I think we're doing all right in the
game. Character is not any
younger. We definitely need to get him
married off soon.
Now, I don't know what the story is with
as far as I know your character can die
of old age. I'm guessing it's probably
around 65 years of age. I'm
guessing, but I don't
know. Oh,
three. However, what we do need to
figure
out is what happens when he does die.
Can you leave him an air to carry
on? Now, this game
has a before and an after. So, you've
got the farmer's
father, which although it came out after
this game, is set before it. You're
actually playing the part
of our
father. Now, I've looked at that one in
the past. At the time, it needed more
work, but I do think we could go back
and have another look at that at some
point.
being the same developers. Hopefully,
they've made improvements to it and it
could be worth trying
again. But then there is another one
which the developers are working
on which is set after this one and
that's going to be Cyber Farmer. I have
no idea what it's like cuz it's still in
development, but that might be one that
I'd like to try as well.
a robot farmer. Yeah, I think something
along those lines. It seems a bit
weird,
but I like this game. And as part of the
story line, I think it could be worth
just at least the very least taking a
look. Is that a tree or a
nice?
Um, definitely worth at least taking a
look to see what it's going to be
like. Yes, I should have brought my
rifle.
Never
mind.
Okay. Thought I saw mushrooms there.
Nope. Right. I didn't actually bring
anything on me,
but how much cigarette? I never thought
about it.
So, oh, I thought she had a sale price
on here as well. A buy and a sell price.
No, we can buy them for 101, but I don't
know what the sale price is. I would
have to have some on me.
Okay. No costa. None at all. What is
that one? Cider. Oh, we're making cider
now.
Okay. So, cider, raspberry,
blueberry,
vodka,
moonshine.
Okay. And it still is, 1100. It's
still,00. Hasn't
changed, right? Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Okay. See, even an apple tree is
something we
need, cuz
apples can be used to feed the animals,
too. Maybe an apple tree would have been
something good early game. I don't
know. But for now, let's head back. We
got some sticks
finally. We'll go check on whatever's
cooking. Where's our bike?
have a quick drink.
How you getting
on?
10,
10, and 11. Okay, so they're actually
still
good. They're still good. Oh, sorry.
What I might do for now is we're just
going to stick that in there. It won't
take it. Oh, we're not going to take it.
Nope, we're not going to take it. What
about this one? No, that won't take it
either. Ah, can we put sticks in here?
Brilliant. All right, let's empty out
our
inventory. So, we could go sell these
berries. Let's actually see what we end
up with. 31
mushrooms. 40 and
152. A lot of raspberry. We really do.
I mean, if I sold the
raspberry, not
chocolates, they're worth five each, I
think. So, that's only 500 if I sold
them. It's not enough for a still. Okay,
it's still not enough for a still. Oh,
we do have this. That can't be right.
Five. Is that the sale price? That can't
be right. Let's
try. Let's sell that. And I am going to
take take those cuz we have way more
than we can deal with right now. So,
let's take a
100. We'll go and sell
that. I'm actually thinking let's just
sell the meat. Let's Okay, here I go.
Let's sell the meat. But let's take the
meat gathering
device. That could be a good way of
going, I
think. And if we're going to go out and
sell, let's get rid of these
two. Okay, 40 and 52. That sounds fair.
I think we'll keep
that. All right, we have 12 yeast. Let's
Oh, I'm too
heavy. Way too
heavy. Put something
back. Actually, actually, hang on.
Rather than put something
back. Well, what we'll do is we'll drop
the coffees. We'll drop our
buns. 158. I'm just thinking if we get
on the
bike, we can get on the
bike. I don't think it takes us any
additional
time cuz we're on the bike. Weight
doesn't matter when you're on the
bike. Let's just let's just let's
just grab the
bite. Bring the bite.
to the
berries. Sure, there's an old proverb
there somewhere. Bring the bike to the
berries. Pretty sure it'll still only
take us about 15
minutes to get to the farm. Yeah, cuz
we're on a bike, the weight doesn't
matter. Or does it? We seem to be biking
really
slow. Stop. Okay. By God, blink and blow
me. It didn't stop.
Me my spry. Me my spry. Exactly. Yeah.
Buy these off us, love. 2,100. Now we're
talking.
All
right. Does this guy buy our meat? I'm
pretty sure he
does. I don't normally sell meat to this
guy. I usually sell meat to the one in
the
town, but pretty
sure.
Beautiful.
Beautiful. All right. So, what does that
give us
now? 2,600. It's enough there for
another couple of stills,
mate. Why are we going
backwards? All
right. No
trial. There you go.
Five. Nice. What is this? Raspberry
mash. Oh,
true. Okay. Well, we want your last
still. Right. I might even buy another
bucket.
$112. No. No. Let's prioritize. I
want I think we're going to go up and
visit Ann or at least go to Ann's farm
and won't be here. She's in the
town. What trees do you have? Oh, you
don't have any trees. I thought she had
some sort of tree here, like an apple or
something.
Apparently not. Do you sell buckets for
the same price? I think yours are
dera. Okay, so all the trees must come
from the forestry. Gentlemen, I I
actually thought this lady had the apple
trees. I'm
You don't sell trees. He does.
Okay. So, we
have popppler, which I've heard is very
popular these days, and birds.
I don't know another tree as charming as
this one. Not only does it
have its snow white bark, but in autumn
the leaves take on beautiful
colors. Yes, these are lots there are
lots of growing around, but lots of them
get turned into fences, sheds, and
outouses. So, we might run out of these
one day.
Okay. Yes, there are lots. Hang on.
The description on fur and popular is
the same. Okay. So, let's
take one of
those. One of those. And we can't afford
that. 756. We're
$45
short.
Man, that just sucks like a
raspberry. All right. 45 freaking
dollars.
Okay, I want to start growing some
trees. Now, we paid 750 for
those. I think I might plant them right
here. Can I plant them this time of
year? Maybe we might have to wait till
spring. And I'll need to ho the
ground.
Okay. I don't know. Do we wait till
spring or do we take a
chance? Take a chance on me. Oh, sorry.
I
think Oh, the tools aren't in here
anymore. Glenn, you moved them. I think
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
planting
them. I think if I get them in the
ground now, it'll be
fine. If it's not, we've just wasted
1,500
bucks. We need a ho ho ho. Merry
Christmas. We need that. Yeah, we're
coming into
winter. Coming into
winter. All right. So, what do I
think? Actually, no. Cuz we have this
line of trees here.
Um I put in a popler
here. 375 hours.
Interesting. Actually, this ground's
already been hoed.
Need to cut down the voltage. Okay.
All
right. For now, we're going to try one
of each tree.
There we go. 375 for a
fur, 375 for a popler. They're the same.
Okay.
Interesting. I've got a little bit of
grass on me. I'm just going to go and
give it to the cows.
Not enough space.
All right. At least then it's not
wasted,
right? It's about the gate over
here. You look like you're longing for
somebody else's farm.
[Laughter]
Cal
375 hours to grow trees. Man, that's a
long time.
All right. What I think we should do is
go out
hunting. Get us some meat. Cuz now that
we've got better control over the
time, hunting is going to be a lot
easier to
do. Still, that's what I was
thinking. Cuz in the past, going out
hunting could take a lot of time.
We'll leave some sticks in
there. What? Oh, yep. Um, grab a bucket
of water. That's all smoky in this
house. Has somebody been smoking in
here?
We're definitely going to have to put
more water into these stills, but it's
enough to get us started for now. We now
have five
stills. I guess it doesn't really make
any difference which one I use,
actually. Oh, no. Cuz it'll take ages
anyway. I was going to say we could do
the raspberry mash now, but no, we got
to cook that.
All right, that's off and
going. Keep the
mash. Oops, this one's mashed clean.
All right.
Um, take these
off. I sold all my meat. So, let's do
some mash. We wanted a raspberry mash.
Can I do a raspberry
mash? Raspberry mash. Must obtained a
recipe. Yeah, it's why we're not doing
it. We might have to buy
it. We may need to buy it. Okay, in that
case, let's do
blueberry. Do they all take the same
length of time? I
wonder. Um, they
should. Did I click the wrong
thing?
Cook. We did blueberry. Don't have any
apple. Oat mash. We could do that one
too to do our
vodka. We got no
potatoes. Okay, so there is only one
mash I can do today.
Oh no, I'm out of sugar. Oh
man, sugar. So now that's going to be a
problem,
too. We're going to have to go and buy
some
sugar. Okay. Right.
Exactly. That's exactly right. We need
sugar. So, we only have 700
bucks. Sugar. Can you get
$700? Not a lot. I bet you, you know, I
don't know about you guys, I like
sugar. I like things that are bad for
me.
I am actually thinking the farm might be
the best
place. Let's see what it's going to cost
us. Rather than buying
sugar, let's see what the beets will
cost. Mimi Bry. Mimi Bry.
Exactly. So, the
beats the beats are 14
[Music]
each. How many can we
buy?
50. All right. Sold. I probably should
have hung on to those other ones
before, but we only had three and you
need
four. That's fine. Head back home.
What's that chicken doing in my potato
patch? And then what we might do is go
out and do some more berry picking cuz
there's not a lot we can do other than
building fences and
things. And I think if we go out berry
picking could be a damn good idea just
to get us some extra cash coming in.
Right.
Cook sugar from beets. Yeah. Four water.
Oh, and six beets. I thought it was
four. That's why I said before we didn't
have
enough. Okay, we'll get some sugar
going. Sugar takes 5 hours 42. The
blueberry mash is about the same. Let's
throw some more wood in
there. About 6 hours.
558. Beautiful. Yep. All right, we're
going to go hunting, berry
picking. I could go fishing. I don't
know. Don't
know. Aussiey's playing out of ore
again.
Yeah, I think we'll we'll head up around
the outside. We'll do some more berry
picking
and if we see any animals this time,
we'll hunt
them. We'll leave our bike here cuz it's
junk. Sort this out while we're at it.
Oh, this is already
done. Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes. I recall
there's something in that mountain and
we need to get that out.
Right. Let's grab our
rifle. Actually, let's hotkey the rifle
for slot five. Is this thing loaded?
Yes. So, sticks, berries, animals,
mushrooms.
This should make us a few green.
Bambi running away.
Yeah, definitely getting close to winter
now. All the rain starting to set in.
Winter will be a good time to do our
building.
We must have already been in here berry
picking. Yeah. All these berry bushes
are
harvested. Yep. We've already been in
here
apparently. Must have been last time I
played. Be more sticks in this forestry
area.
Berry bush is right here.
What? Oh, in the rock face. That's a
cool place for a berry bush to be
growing. Sorry, just having a quick sip
of my
coffee. All
right, there's another berry bush in the
[Laughter]
cliff. What am I stuck on?
You're not complaining. and hunt Call of
the Wild again. Haven't played that for
a few weeks, have
I? We might have to go on a community
hunt again sometime soon. It's been a we
while. What about some of you
new community members?
Have you do you play Hunter Call of the
Wild? We used to go on a bit of a
community hunt
together. Haven't been on one for a
while. Nice relaxing
game like this is now. Nice and
relaxing. Good bit of fun going out
hunting every so often.
Come here. Freaking
egg. No animals out here in the open.
kind of hoping I might see something out
here in the
open. I was hoping to find something in
the open. Okay.
Um, typical. I bring him a gun and we're
not seeing any damn thing to shoot now.
We're going to have more than enough
berries to do mash. I mean, one bottle
of mash.
What is it? 3 and 1/2 hours in game.
Well, to brew. It's actually 4 and a
half in real life.
So at that rate, you're only
getting few bottles a day.
Anyhow, so the 50 odd that we
have should be
plenty. We might be able to sell more of
them quite
frankly. Oh, looking at the wrong tree.
They're both looking
red. Ah,
now found you. Found this earlier, but I
couldn't remember where we found it.
Hell, this is a quest that we're on at
the moment, but
um we might have to bring a spanner to
it.
Oh, nope. It's ours. It's already
ours. So, first gear has no fuel. Okay,
if that's the case, let's Oh, I just hit
the damn tree. Oh, Gen, what did you hit
the tree
for? All right. Um, can we push?
No, I can't
push. Can I use my physical body to
push? I shouldn't hit the damn tree,
should
I? We were coasting downhill until I did
that. Come on, get off the tree. Come
back with some fuel.
No, we'll come back with fuel cuz I'm
just wasting time otherwise. All right,
where exactly are
we? We're just behind the sawmill next
to the river.
Who do you and I bring? Okay, we're
right behind the buildings. We should be
able to easy find that.
We'll get some gas. We'll come back.
Grab our
motorcycle. We're not lost. We just
found a
motorcycle. So, I did find that earlier,
as I say, but we couldn't do anything
with it. Only. Now, one of the quests
that I did
recently, he told me about the bike out
in the bush or we discussed it. I can't
remember quite how it came about, but
during that quest when I completed it, I
was told we can have the bike. So,
that's our new
transport. Bet it'll be better than a
bicycle.
Reload.
Yeah, we just got to get some gas. I
couldn't remember where it was. And one
of the things I had in the back of my
mind was, let's try and find the
motorcycle while we're out
here. Fall over you stupid pig.
Damn pig. Stop
running. Why is this pig running away
from a man with a gun? That makes no
sense. Why would a pig ever run away
from a man with a
gun? Silly damn pig. You know how many
berries we probably missed cuz of you?
All over. Thank you.
Okay. Right. Let's pick you up. Where
are we going to take you
to? Oh, we're a long way from a
road. Free range bacon. Definitely
freerange bacon is yum.
Nobody's ever had wild
pork. There's a huge difference in
taste. Any wild animal though, there's a
big difference in taste. When I used to
breed my own chickens, cuz they were
truly free range.
Even though I eat a lot of chicken and I
love chicken. When I had my freerange
chickens, the flavor to them was so
strong that I actually didn't like a
roast chicken. I actually had to do
other things with them. So, I made
chicken
soup
or chicken pie or something
else because the taste was so much
stronger.
I kind of want to go and get
that. Oh, there's another
pig. Kind of want to go and get that gas
now.
Don't run from me, pig.
Oh, then the deer ran
too. Trying to get a head shot, but it's
not easy. Not when they stand side on to
you. Damn pig. Stop running.
I wonder if we can stick a trailer on
the motorcycle. I know we can stick
Fluffy on the motorcycle and take Fluffy
for a ride. We might have to do
that just for a bit of fun. Grab Fluffy
and stick him on the motorcycle in the
side car of the motorcycle. I know you
can do that cuz I've seen the picture of
it.
screaming. I bet you that's what that
pig was thinking while I was chasing
after him with a gun.
Crazy man with a gun. Run.
So, what have we got? Two pigs so
far. I think we'll be all right when we
sell these berries. Sell that
meat. I think I'm just going to sell the
meat and the skins and everything for
now.
rather than make clothes or any cooking.
I think we just want some fast
cash so we can get ready
for next
spring. So that those two trees we
planted 365 hours or whatever it said.
I'm guessing that's an entire
year. I'm guessing it's one
year. I would be very keen to know what
sort of money we can make out of
them cuz forestry should in theory be a
relatively good income.
You
only have some luck. I tell you what, we
need to figure out what the
best money-making crop is. Cuz I mean,
somebody asked me on the Discord and
it's not for that reason, but if we can
figure out what the best money-making
crop
is, start really making some
money. I do have to laugh cuz with the
farmlands this
good, it seems very much that the
developers are quite happy to sit back
and let the community just help each
other. And it seems at the moment
everybody seems to think, even though
it's a lie, it's incorrect. Well, it's
not a lie. It's an incorrect assumption.
They all seem to think I'm a professor
and I know everything about this game.
Far from
it. Yeah, I've been asking answering a
few questions on the Discord and trying
to help other people
get problems solved that I've
had. I would prefer questions came on
the video. So guys, if any of you from
the Discord rather than asking me
questions on the
Discord, ask me questions on the
video cuz that helps to promote the
video in the algorithm. YouTube
considers
it
interaction and leaving a comment on a
video always helps a lot to promote that
video.
So, if any of you ever feel like coming
in and leaving a comment on a video
afterwards, I'd appreciate it. And I
answer all the
questions, all the comments, whether it
be a question or just a
comment. It helps to promote the video
in the algorithm. And most people don't
leave any comments on my videos. I don't
know why. Maybe they think I don't need
comments. I'm not
sure. But it does help. rightly in the
algorithm. I know one of our community
members,
Oddball, always actually asks people to
go and leave comments after the videos,
but yeah, look at
that. I don't know how successful he is
with
that. All I know is it makes a huge
difference.
If you guys want to leave comments after
the video in the comment section, I'd
appreciate it and I'll definitely
respond to
them. Where are
we? Okay, let's take that carcass to the
nearest road. Where was it? Right there.
So, the nearest road is that
one. Yes.
One shot straight through the
head. Now he's dead. That was a good
shot. Even if I do say so myself.
We'll come back with a trailer for
collect all of these up later. Who was
that other one?
Don't run, pig.
What's wrong with him?
What's wrong with him? He seemed
broken. Right, we'll pick you up. Get
you off the track. What you with that
one? There's a fox.
We're doing all right with the hunt
now. Missed. Let's get a bit
closer. Don't be rude. Trying to shoot
you. That's just being rude. Trying to
run
away. Have some manners, Fox. Lay down.
I'll try and get as many as I can along
this
roadway cuz then it means we can just
turn up later with the tractor, pick
them all up at the same
time. Look at them all. Freaking
awesome, mate.
Drop this with the other
one. Two in the same spot just makes it
easier. Now, what time is it? It seems
to be getting a little
dark. Uh, it's only
lunchtime. It might be about to rain.
Now, with all this extra time on our
hands, we might actually be able to make
some really good money just hunting
alone.
Why have you got your head buried in a
tree? Had his head buried in a tree.
Let's try and get a head
shot. Whoa, we're getting a bit of
freezing today. Apologize.
Maybe I should turn my settings
down. Wonder if that would make a big
difference. Let's have a quick look.
Settings. Visual
quality.
Post-processing. Texture
quality. Lamp shadows. Shadow quality
can go down.
average. I'm not sure what anti-aliasing
does. Texture
quality. I don't know. Feat quality.
We'll go down to
average. See if that just helps to
avoid some of the freezing.
I've got a damn good computer. It
shouldn't be
freezing, but this game tends to freeze
a little.
Right next to the road. Perfect.
Why am I not getting There we go.
Spamming the E key and it wasn't picking
it up.
I do find sticks a little hard to pick
up sometimes. The hit boxes aren't huge.
Ah, is that him over
there? Oh, that's a fox,
though. I don't have the recipe for rat
soup. You got to have recipes. You can't
make things without recipes. If you got
the recipe for rat soup, you let me
[Laughter]
know. Yeah, we need the recipe
first. Just like we need the recipe for
raspberry mash, we need the recipe for
rat soup as well.
Fox. Foxes are good cuz you can just
pick them straight up and put them in
your
backpack. Not that we have a backpack,
but you know what I mean.
Right
away. Oh, I thought he was coming
towards us. Thought I'd pick up a couple
of sticks while he was coming towards
us. Turns out he's not. I might have
scared him off.
Give me. Give me. Give me.
Where was
he? Looked down to pick up that and now
I've lost
sight. Oh
well. It was a pig there. I saw
it. I think I'm getting a little heavy.
Yes, I am. Okay, so let's do this pig.
We'll head home, go get some gas for our
motorcycle, and then we can all start to
sing the motorcycle song.
[Laughter]
to you an operator.
Stop freezing.
Turn down the freaking settings.
Where's that
pig? Let's get it
off. Any more carcasses just here? Yes,
there
is. Bugger.
Got to take a quick snap at
him. I hit a fox.
Oh, straight over his head. Yeah, I'll
go back and get the
trailer. Still over his
head. Actually, what I could do is if we
put all of this
down, we're going to be able to move a
little quicker.
We're coming back with the trailer
anyway. Everything here in one
spot. What? What did I just hit? I think
it was Q. Oh, it was Q's a auto
run. Stupid fox. Stop running away,
coward. Get back here and fight like a
real
man. Says a guy shooting small animals
with a gun.
Oh, kind of wanted that white fox, too.
Kind of.
Still missing that damn fox. How many
times have I missed that same fox
now? Barely worth the amount of bullets
I spent on
it. That was too low. I've been trying
to get the right distance, but
[Laughter]
No, stop running, pig. That's not a pig
thing. Damn foxes cost me a fortune.
It's gone now. That one fox, he's cost
me like 10
bullets. All right, let's head home.
Let's go get that
gas. I feel funny sitting on the back of
the bike.
Where am
I? Need to go
left. Where's that damn
fox? Feel like I'm on the back of the
bike. How'd that happen? I zoomed out.
How do I change the zoom? Whoa. V
button. That'll look
[Laughter]
cool. All right. The V
button. Right. Leave you
there. How much gas do we even
have? Cuz we're going to need Oh, we got
a bit. And so we're going to need gas
for the
tractor. Okay. Our gun needs fixing.
What is that going to
take? Tools. Okay. Do we still have
tools in here?
All right, let's grab the track guitar
track. Yep, we're good. Uh, refuel
it. Watch out if I was you, chicken. I'm
not good with this machine.
straight in front of
us. We'll gather up all the animals that
we've
[Applause]
shot. Can't shoot on the tractor.
missed.
All right, let's just admit I'm a bad
shot. Move on.
Oh, come on. That was a head
shot. That's just
rude. Okay, so the first one's just to
the right.
Not with a view. Why do I keep ending up
behind?
It feels very strange being
behind,
right? We might as well go down to the
road and go up that way.
Come
on, old
girl. Oh, do you have to keep your
finger on the accelerator? Okay. See, I
was thinking cuz it's a tractor, you
don't need to do that. But apparently
you
do. In real life with a tractor, you
just pull the throttle
lever down to the position where you
want it.
And then it'll just stay at that
speed. Can I shoot through this barn?
Should be able to,
right? No. Apparently, you can't. Oh,
they're running for their
lives. I forgot about that. People don't
like it when you pull out a gun and
start shooting me at them. Don't know
why. It's kind of
bizarre. Don't get in front of my
tractor, boys. I run you
[Applause]
over. Oh, you ran away, too. It's just
rude.
Got the wrong
side. Oops. Didn't mean to gut on sight
to get less meat.
[Applause]
No, it's not what I said. Pick it back
up. Right.
And then we'll take all these we'll take
all these home and we'll gut them this
evening. Thought I butchered them
anyway. All right, just ignore the damn
bullet. What
the Can you pretend to at least be dead?
They're not doing a very good job of
pretending to be dead, are
they? I'm not sure. Is that hitting the
bush in front of
it? Six.
Oh, come on. All you're doing is wasting
my bullets. We definitely need that
better gun.
How many bullets do I have left? Only
four left. Oh well, let's use up the
last of our bullets then, shall we?
Where's that big white stag
gone? Really wanted that big white stag.
It's not actually a white, is it?
But Oh, come on. I've only got four
bullets. Don't do this to me. It's rude.
Get back here.
You come towards me. That's it.
Was that last comment on this day?
This is my last
bullet.
Missed. Oh, we got
one. That freaking fox. He just keeps
getting further and further away. Oh,
wait. Hang on.
Nope.
I'm out of
ammo. All
right, we're going to have to spend this
money on more ammo.
See, now that they I've got no ammo,
that fox is not afraid of
me. All right. Where is our
tractor? Oh, there's that carcass over
there, too.
We got plenty of meat. We'll go sell the
meat. We'll um get some more
bullets. We got all those berries to
sell as well.
Bring the tracker a bit closer.
[Applause]
The lawnmowing crew are here. It's going
to get noisy soon. Okay. I can't get
out. I can't get up there cuz you pigs
in the
way. A
rare. Nope. Get back
here. Escape. It's too late for that.
You're already being shot. You're dead.
You do a gymnastics thing. I don't
mind. That bag didn't fit. It fitted.
It okay. Well, that one did. So, the
bags aren't going on properly,
but there we go.
Yeah, lawn mowing crew is here, so it's
going to get noisy
shortly. Oh, now just put these in your
inventory. Clean.
Let them all now sitting next to the
road like they feel
safe just cuz they know I got no
freaking
bullets. Go
away. Okay, I'm going to have to climb
up.
Ah, what is
that? No, not closed. Mr. Climb
on. Can you please behave?
And I fell off. Oh, come
on. You don't have to be difficult about
this, pig. All right, behave yourself,
please. Still trying to figure out the
best way to load as many animals onto
the tractor as possible.
because they're a little awkward to load
as you can
tell. Right, you're
on. Oh, I think I know what it is. I'm
on the downhill slope, so I'm having
trouble reaching up. That could be what
it is.
Can you throw it?
I haven't thought about that. Let's try
throwing
it. Oh, that worked. Who would have
thought you could throw it?
Should have should have thought of that
earlier.
That is not climbing
game. Okay. It doesn't like that, does
it? Okay. Let's try throwing it on
then. Oh, here you go. That'll work.
[Applause]
I think that went straight over the
other side, didn't it?
No, not gut on sight.
A you get less meat if you go on site.
Nope. Can you behave,
please? Nope. You're not going
to climb on either. It's too full now, I
think. Oh, it doesn't like me doing
that, does it?
Beautiful. I didn't hear it make a noise
though, so it may not be on there
properly.
See if we can rotate it around rather
than the
legs being
on. Ah, keep it and get on
sight. Not what I want. It's costing us
meat. I'm sure it
is. There we go. I heard that one.
Yeah, I think one of these might fall
off.
[Applause]
No
noise. Makes a noise when it goes on
correctly. Yeah, you're fine. You made
the noise. That's all that
matters. All right, that's all about
carcasses.
While I was looking at the map, I very
nearly hit a rock.
There's a few hours work here.
I should be throwing them. I keep
forgetting you can throw
them. Can you throw? Thank you.
See if we can throw it right over the
top. Not even close.
blanking mower. Anyway,
Chicken looking at all the dead animals
thinking, "I got to get out of here.
This man's gone crazy.
Oh, what a
stat. Just seeing how much I can stack
it
now. Stay up there. Ah, that's
rude. What do you reckon,
dog? I got all of
those. What time is it? 1:00.
Oops. Oh, that might have been a bit
much. Oh, dropped the foxes.
Drop the
gas now. Can we move here?
All right, that's all we can fit in
there is 97.
Okay, good enough.
And you still got eight.
Okay. How does this get
on? 3 hours. You still got plenty of
time. Oh, this is so much better with a
slow
speed. Getting so much more done today.
Look at these
animals. Freaking awesome.
That bounced
back. Okay, whatever. Right, let's go
get our
motorcycle and then we'll come back and
gut all of those. Run, chicken.
But not that
way. 14 hours on the
spuds. All right, we just
teleport fast
travel now. Hang
on. So that's his farm. Motorcycle must
be
here. That can't be right. It was behind
the sawmill.
I thought it was behind
Thaddius. We did pick that fuel up. I
didn't grab the
fuel. I took the fuel off the
tractor. Oops.
Right, let's try that again. Was it
actually Thaddius or was it the sawmill?
I'm sure it was behind
Thaddius. Ruined church. Yeah. So, was
it in there or over here? Don't think it
was next to the ruined church, was
it? I'm lost. That's your fault, Dez,
cuz Yuri is telling me I'm lost.
Where was
it? Yeah,
exactly. I think it must have been
behind the ruined church, was it?
Actually, while we're
here. Oh, look at all
this. Oh, it's 25. Look like so much
more. Gather all this up while we're
here.
Um, that thing looks like it might be a
bad idea to play with. We don't have a
loaded
gun. Where did he
go? We're supposed to hunt that
thing. Where did he
go? Oh, there he is. There he is. Run.
I hope you can't get in here. Freaking
heck.
Quiet. Now, I've been up here already,
but let's just take another look. Now
that time has slowed
down, maybe we'll see something we
didn't before.
Oh, I didn't mean to stick
down. Where's the bear
gone? That's what you usually say when
all the booze is gone. Where's the bear
gone? Now, did we check this? Yeah, I
thought so.
Can we see the motorbike from
here? Nothing in the bird's
nest. I want to try and ring the
bell. Oh, we can get in here, but we
can't ring the bell. I was thinking I
wasn't going to get going to be able to
get here cuz I thought I'd fall
down. Where is me
cycle? Whoa, whoa,
whoa. Oh
Oh
man. I presume that beer will kill me
given half a chance. Even quarter of a
chance, I presume.
Where did he go
now? Okay, we know where the bear
is. Hi,
bear. We know where he is now. We can
come back and try to get him later.
Let's go this way. And let's just
run. We'll see if we can get a bravery
award. Run.
Oops. Probably shouldn't have done that.
It's a bear following us.
No, we might have lost
him. We either outsmarted him or out
maneuvered him. Maybe even both.
Where's that freaking
bicycle? Uh, M. No, we've definitely
not sure. It was near Thaddius, wasn't
it?
Mushrooms must be over this
way. Maybe I should have come back with
the rifle. I do have my rifle. Oh, yeah.
But I don't have any bullets. It's not
going to help me. I need the
bullets. I need to refill my refill.
Where the stinking heck was that
motorcycle? Can't believe I've lost
it. Disappear.
Uh, where was
it? I really think maybe I should just
go home, get all that meat, and we'll
come back when we have more bullets so I
can take out that beer.
I'm freaking lost. All right. Was it
behind the sawmill? I'm sure it was near
Thaddius. Damn sure it was near
Thaddius, but let's head over
here. Oh, guys, I haven't got my gun out
today. Calm
down. Whoa. Did you see that?
That man can
fly literally,
figuratively, probably in other ways as
well. Okay, here it is. Here it
is. No, no, no.
Refill. Yeah, now we got a
broom. Don't crash this stinking thing
as soon as you get it, Glenn. At least
wait five
[Applause]
minutes. This seems quite fast actually.
Find out in a minute when I get out onto
the open.
Not afraid to go fast in here, though.
[Music]
Oh, you
idiot. He ran straight in front of the
bloody
bike. I don't think you can kill them,
can you? Far route, man. What a
monkey. He ran straight in front of me
bike. All
right. See what sort of speed this
thing's
got. Oh, Glenn. Glenn, stop.
Wow. It's changing gears. This thing's
not easy to ride, man. This thing is not
easy to ride. It slides.
[Applause]
I don't know if I like
it. Every little turn is quite dramatic.
Plus, I've found every vehicle in this
game seems to pull to the blowen
left. I don't know
why. We can do 30 km per hour. 35. Look
at the boys. 42.
[Applause]
Oh, well, we got
it. Yeah, even if it does feel like it's
um crazy machine, we got it. That's the
good news. All right. And it is 1:00 in
the
afternoon. Should I? Yeah, there's a few
hours work in this. Let's do this. I
don't want to be up all night doing
it. See, 39 minutes per animal. There's
about a dozen animals
here. Yeah. See, it's getting dark now.
Oh, we're pretty
heavy. Uh, we'll drop the toes.
Drop the mates.
You're not close enough.
be interested to see what time it is.
Definitely getting
dark. Oh, look at that. I'm glad I
didn't leave it too much
later. Let's turn the light on. Make
sure everything's
done. Pardon me.
Okay, let's go empty out this
weight. Now, I'm pretty sure we have one
more
day to sell this
meat.
Pretty sure it wasn't a complete waste
of meat. We've got all the
carcasses, but the meat has to be sold
before the end of winter if I'm not
mistaken. So, we have at least one more
day, I
think, at least.
58 bits of
meat. All right, let's head to
bed. How we doing for time? Two and
three hours for a day. God blam
me. We're not going to get another day
out of it then, are we? Let's get up at
8:00.
I mean, 3 hours. I could call it a day,
but
I want to sell all this
meat. Okay, so let's add something to
eat. Some animals will die soon. That's
what happens.
die eventually. We all get there one
day. That's
why everybody should always take care of
each other. Make sure that
you
don't get you nowhere.
Thank
you. All right. So, we're going to sell
all this meat
today. So, I'll keep the fuel cuz we're
probably going to run
out. Mushrooms.
All right, we need to buy
ammo. Woof woof. Oh, sorry. Dog's still
asleep. Dog got it. There's more
meat. More
mushrooms. Let's see what we can make
out of this
lot. I'm going to sell these berries.
cuz we can't do those ones. So, let's
just sell
them. That wasn't all of them
anyway. Ah, it's not even all of them.
Oh, man. I'm so
heavy. Okay, hang on. Let's
One didn't
stack. There we go.
Oh, true. I've never bothered
to never actually bothered to put any of
these up on the wall.
Just the
one. Put our fox heads above the wall.
We could
put our deer over the
bed. A pig up there.
Right. Um, grab
these. I could have sold them, but I
just thought, let's decorate the house
with a few. What am I stuck on? Oh,
motorcycle.
I left the light on all night last
night. That's cost me some power.
I should not have left the light
on. You know the song, don't leave the
light on for me. Oh, never mind. Right,
that's What time is it? It's 1:00 in the
stinky
morning. What do you mean it's 1:00 in
the morning? I thought I slept until a
proper time. I didn't, did I? Oh well.
Can we make anything out of this? Oh, I
need the spring and the wall.
I thought we slept through the night. I
must have only slept for 1 hour. Oh
well. Albino set. Nice. Albino set too.
Nice. We can't do the bear set. The
black set. The bore set. The bore
set. Hang on. No, we just need Yep. We
need more
spring. Okay, we're going to make some
clothes and then we'll go back to bed
again cuz apparently I forgot to sleep
through the night. But we got some cool
new winter
clothing. So the beer set. No black set.
Bore set. Four. Three. Bore
furs. I only have two. Ah, I have deer.
Okay, I only have the deer. So, deer
set. Deer set. That's all we can
do. Be fur.
We need potato mash for doing the
springtime set. We'll get that done
before spring, summertime set, and a
work set. Oh, we've got lots of clothing
now. I'll go sell the rest of my fur
rather than hang on to
it. I'll sell
it. Oh, wait. That's not where we
putting clothes now, is
it? Uh, should we use this one? Cuz it's
where I put Yeah, we'll put all of it
together.
Oh, we got two of the
same. I wonder if we can sell
them. Never
mind. Okay. So, what's this? Fur
cat. Fur
vest. Fur
hat. Well, aren't they all winter?
Aren't they all winter clothing? I'm a
little confused by that. Let's go back
and have another
look. Yeah, maybe what we could do is
actually call it a day cuz we have been
going for 3
hours. We did the deer
set. Oh, I can do
more. True. And the albino set. Oh, that
was the difference. I did the albino
set,
right? Okay. But I don't think we can
sell
clothing. Let's just have a look and see
if it has a
value. I'm not sure if that's a value.
No, it's weight and storage capacity.
It's not value. Ah, okay. Yeah, I don't
know if we can sell this
stuff. I
think what we'll do is we'll keep one of
each on us and we'll try and sell them
tomorrow. I probably
can't,
but why not give it a try? If I can
start selling clothing. Yeah, why not?
All right, I think what we'll do because
it has been three hours and I didn't
sleep a full
night and I've just noticed YouTube has
started buffering. There we go. I don't
know why YouTube's buffering, but I'm
having a bit of a slow internet week. I
have noticed
that sometime my YouTube pages aren't
loading fully.
All right. I think what we'll do is
we'll try and sell all of
this. Yeah, it's back again
now. We'll try and sell all of that next
time we play. So, we'll call that it for
today. Next time we come back, we got
all that and all of this stuff. We're
going to try and sell all of
it. We're already after
midnight, so our food's not going to go
off. Yeah, hopefully. That's a lot of
good stuff to sell. So, yes, I'm going
to call that it for the day. I'll call
that it for the stream. And next week
when we come back, we're going to sell
all of that stuff. I kind of like it
with that on the wall. That's kind of
cool. We're going have to start
decorating our house this winter, too.
Um, yeah. So, we'll be back to this
again next week. Thank you everybody for
watching. Hopefully, you've enjoyed
today's stream. If you have, you know
what to do. Give it a thumbs up if
you're on YouTube. Subscribe if you're
um new to the channel. Follow if you're
on
Twitch and if you feel like leaving me a
comment afterwards on the video. It's
always appreciated and I do respond to
all comments and
feedback. Otherwise, we'll see you all
next time. Take care. Have a wonderful
afternoon, evening, whatever it is,
wherever you're from. And hopefully
we'll see you all again next time. Bye
y'all.
Thank you to all the channel members.
Tinty7 and Queen Seda Dogface Mark Era
no access to name Lord Fletch Daz and
Tiger Sweet Michelle Mabel Noah Astro
Skippy Oldtime Aussie Oddball Gaming and
Muton. And thank you Scrapneck for
the bits. Appreciate it. Uh we also had
didn't we have somebody else donate bits
today? Uh let's quickly check quickly
check
event.
[Music]
I feel like we did Clint.
I need to keep track of
that. Anyway, appreciate it. I've gone
back two days now. Definitely not there.
I need a better system to keep track of
it. Cheers, guys. I do appreciate the
bits. Thank you.
[Music]
Twitch activity.
Scrap
[Music]
Nick and old Tom Rosie was yesterday.
Okay, cool. Yep.
When you